buenas tardes valentina con mucha
tranquilidad se ha desarrollado esta
primera de estas elecciones históricas
en la que los ciudadanos chilenos han
acudido a las urnas a ejercer su derecho
cívico de forma pausada tranquila sin
incidentes destacables recordemos que
estas son unas elecciones históricas en
muchos sentidos en el número de
candidatos que se postulan más de 16.000
en el número de cargos que se eligen más
de 2700 entre ellos 255 constituyentes y
también con las papeletas para votar más
largas de la historia de chile por la
gran cantidad de números y de candidatos
que se pueden registrar en algunos
distritos son papeletas con incluso 80
100 candidatos en distritos lo que hace
difícil la el plegar el voto y poder
depositarlo en las urnas
patricia debía gran expectativa sobre la
afluencia de votantes porque en esta
ocasión pues el voto es voluntario y se
temía que la participación fuera baja a
causa del temor por el coi 19 hay
estimativos de cuántas personas
asistieron a las urnas
pues en este momento nos encontramos en
la sede del servicio electoral donde
aproximadamente en unos 50 minutos se
dará una primera estimación de cuántas
personas han participado ha participado
efectivamente hoy en las elecciones pero
si podemos decir que ha habido bastantes
filas en los colegios electorales se han
visto en muchos lugares de santiago y en
otros lugares de chile largas y village
en los colegios e incluso personas que
no han alcanzado a votar a las 6 en
algunos colegios no se les permitía si
estaban fuera del recinto y tendrán que
volver mañana lo que podría indicar una
gran participación muy similar a la del
plebiscito del pasado 25 de octubre en
el que se batió récord en cuanto a la
participación de población absoluta el
participo de un 51 por ciento en esta
ocasión de los votantes convocados a las
urnas